CBS News confirms the Justice Department
has opened a criminal investigation to
find out how its own probe of Russian
election interference began in 2016 the
FBI and intelligence agencies found
Russia acted to help president Trump's
campaign but the president claims he was
the investigators original target Paula
Reed is at the White House Paula what
does this mean for the president and the
new CBS News has learned that the
prosecutor overseeing this case will now
have the power to subpoena witness
testimony and documents and even in
panel a grand jury and filed criminal
charges so this is a political win for
President Trump who for two years has
railed against the legitimacy of the
Russia investigation insisting that it
was started by deep state intelligence
officials who wanted to prevent his
election but in a statement House
Judiciary Committee Chairman Jerry
Nadler and House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Adam Schiff said these reports
if true raised profound new concerns
that the Department of Justice under a G
bar has lost its independence and become
a vehicle for president Trump's
political revenge Attorney General
William bar has closely overseen this
investigation even traveled to Italy to
personally secure its assistance he also
asked President Trump to reach out to
foreign leaders including Australia to
ask for their help in this matter
Paula where could this criminal probe
lead and could there be charges it's
unclear what criminal charges Anthony
could be filed against the officials who
were involved in the early months of
this probe sources have suggested in
recent weeks that it's actually unlikely
any criminal charges will be filed but
by opening a criminal investigation and
gathering just enough damaging
information the Attorney General could
still hand President Trump a political
win right in the middle of the 20/20
campaign season
all right Paula thank you